wir kommen zum nächsten zuschauer fall
klaus jakob hat reise ärger und er hat
uns auch ein video geschickt
ich habe am 30 05 20 19 für mich und für
meinen sohn flüge nach südafrika weiter
im vorstand seien gegen bucht aufgrund
des kroner virus und der reisewarnung
des auswärtigen amtes sind diese reisen
leider nicht zustande gekommen und ich
sollte mich an ein sogenanntes gutschein
portal finden ich habe der lufthansa
mails geschickt bzw ein einschreiben mit
rückschein und um die rückzahlung meines
geldes gebeten auf den einschreibebrief
mit rückschein
trotz fristsetzung ist bis heute keine
antwort erfolgt was mir große sorge
macht das dir als kleine kunden mit
unserem eingezahlten geld dann praktisch
auf der strecke bleiben
ja ich kann den ärger durchaus verstehen
lufthansa versichert uns noch ein
bisschen geduld zu haben und dann wird
es da auch das geld geben vor allem
ankommt ist dass ihr das interessante
letztlich braucht man auch gar keinen
gutschein zu akzeptieren
so ist das der die reiseveranstalter und
fluggesellschaften dürfen gutscheine
anbieten
der reisende kann das auch akzeptieren
wenn ihr das denn möchte aber er muss es
nicht und es gibt also keine so
gutschein pflicht wie es ja bei tickets
in deutschland im moment eingeführt
worden ist das gibt es bei reise bei
flügen nicht man muss es also nicht
akzeptieren deshalb sind die angebote
jetzt auch interessanter geworden das
war es war ja lange umstritten ob diese
gutschein regelung kommt oder nicht sie
konnte aber jetzt nicht und dadurch
werden die angebote der gesellschaften
auch besser manchmal gibt es da noch
einen bonus dazu so dass man schon
überlegen sollte akzeptiere ich den
gutschein und bei reisen haben wir auch
bei pauschalreisen haben wir
beispielsweise auch eine
insolvenzsicherung was ja auch ganz
interessant ist so dass man eigentlich
gar kein risiko eingeht und
man aber das geld haben will kann man
darauf drängen und wenn ich bezahlt wird
da muss man ganz ehrlich sagen am ende
des tages hilft tatsächlich dann nur ein
klageverfahren ein mahnverfahren und da
ist unsere erfahrung dann wird sehr
schnell bezahlt